she like as without any warning she just
took the razor
and she started
cutting um
my genitals
it's a different kind of pain like you
go into shock
and my body just became absolutely numb
[Music]
when was the first time you heard about
anything
related to female genetic mutilation
i grew up in
morducho somalia i remember when i was
six years old we had
practically the whole
village um were
you know coming up to us and people
would approach us majority were women
and they would say you know you're doing
something amazing you're going to become
a woman
you know you're going to be clean more
respected
and so i knew that it was something
rather important from what everybody was
saying but as a child
living in a place where it was so normal
you know
the practice fgm was so normalized that
we never saw anyone get it done
so we just took everybody's word for it
and we were very excited
is it true that there are different
types of fgm
type one is where they
either partly remove or fully remove
just the clitoris
a type 2 is when if
they partly remove or fully remove the
clitoris
and the libya
type 3 is the
part removal or the full removal of the
clitoris the
libya some cases the libya majora
and your son
as well type 4 is just like a category
of everything else
it was myself and two of my cousins and
we were taken to my grandma's house
and
when we came in i noticed that there was
a woman there
another no my fat older family members
came and they were just you know
standing around hovering around
and then they said okay who wants to go
first i knew that there was no way that
i was gonna go first
so i
just stayed quiet normally i'm the first
to you know put my hand up and my cousin
you know
she went first and
the moment
i think she's like you know she was
walking so calm and then when she got to
this um chair it was it's like made out
of skin
and
the moment she sat down on it
it was i think four or five family
members who were there and the cutter
they just grabbed her
with like it was so quick i don't even
know how to describe it it was
you know they one person was holding on
to her our um hands
and
then two people were held into onto
their her legs
opened it wide and
this it started cutting it wasn't even
you know let me prepare her for this it
was just
like instant and the razor was about
that big and it had like
uh blades on either end
they put a cloth over her mouth so the
screaming
you know wasn't so loud
um because this procedure was done to us
without any um
painkillers any anesthetics
and she just started cutting so when me
and my other cousin saw the blood
we got so scared and the screaming
so we ran
and we ran as fast as we could in
opposite direction
and
but my uncles were there so they ran
after us and managed to bring us back
because obviously our tiny little legs
couldn't get anywhere
and we were brought back and by the time
we came back
my cousin was being sewn
and i can't explain to you like sitting
there
and dreading and knowing
what's about to happen to you and there
is nothing you can do to stop it and
when my cousin was done they
like put her legs together tied it with
a cloth
picked her up and placed her on the
floor like so carefully just
place that out
like nothing happened like everything
just that just happened was okay
and then
it was my turn but obviously i was
fighting i was like
there is no way you're going to put me
on that chair without a fight there just
there's just no way and
being a six-year-old i did not have that
much strength and i had an adult hold
one hand and i don't hold the other
and out of one leg and add on another
leg
and
they just
pushed me down onto the chair and try to
keep me
as still as possible
it's another
level of terror to know that the people
that were supposed to protect you were
the ones doing this to you
and whilst i was sat on the chair and
you know my limbs were being held down
i noticed i turned to the cutter and i
looked down
and she had a jar
an open jar
and it had
bits which obviously now i
being an adult i know is
genitals
bits and pieces
libya clitoris libya majora
and access skin
were all in the jar and they were just
bloody and
i felt abs i felt sick
i felt sick sick sick and
she like as without any warning she just
took the razor
and she started
cutting
my genitals
and i believe she caught
my clitoris
and
my
libya
and
then and access skin i think
and then she shot it together
and she sewed it
whilst i was
awake
i don't i can't even describe the
feeling of being so alive like
it's
it's a different kind of pain like you
go into shock
and my body just became absolutely
numb
so they sew
the
top of the vagina
all the way down
and they leave a
tiny hole tiny hole
for when you get married
that it's
tiny it's almost impossible
to penetrate impossible
i i didn't know how to react and you
know i was fighting so much
after when it came to the sewing i
stopped fighting
because my body didn't know what to do
um
and
they
tied my legs together
they lift me up and they put me down
next to my cousin and then we had to
watch
my
other cousin have her procedure done i
didn't know but they slaughtered an
animal before hand
and they drained all the blood out so
they put
the blood all over us from head to toe
covered us in blood literally washed us
in blood
and then told us to stand there
um until the blood dried
and i don't know i think we stood there
for at least an hour or over an hour
and then we were washed
off the blood
and then we just never spoke about it
trying to urinate after fgm is just
is a really
traumatizing experience within itself
because
one is not as easy anymore and two it
hurts
it stings it's painful and you just have
to live through it
you know you'll be fine eventually it's
okay this pain will go away
there's no you know let me take you to a
doctor let me see if there's anything
wrong let me see if you've got an
infection
no you just had to live through it or
die
there's no other
option really
so many young women have bled to death
bled to death because of this procedure
and i am
so lucky
that i didn't bleed to death at the back
of at the front of my grandma's house i
am truly
truly
grateful
that
i wasn't
part of you know the
hundreds and thousands if not millions
that have lost their lives
to this procedure
and were
any other women in your family subject
to that everyone
everyone
older than me anyway even younger
everyone
was fgm legal in somalia at that time
i think it still is
it's very legal and there's
it's not frowned upon
it's not
i think it's been happening for so long
that it's become part of culture
it's become
like deep rooted
within our community that it's
they just you know it's like going to a
dentist or you know just
go visiting a doctor they make it seem
like it's something really simple and
it's needed otherwise
you'll get shamed they were i think
the girls that were late to get it done
were shaped they couldn't go anywhere
they couldn't walk down the road without
being you know
you know they say things like oh you
have a clitoris it's disgusting or
oh you're on cuts you know you're dirty
or you're not a woman and
a girl not having had her circumcision
even marriage they worried about a
six-year-old's marriage
you know
in the future how could you know if she
doesn't have fgm how that could possibly
affect her
and you know had the husband my rejecter
the family members might reject her so
it was like trying to
get it done now so that later she's
ready for something but you just
none of us know what that something is
as i got older i started to realize that
they
performed these pr
fgm in order to stop a woman from having
sex before marriage
and that is the plain plain main reason
and to control her sexuality and to
focus more on
her husband's um pleasure than her own
because the you're
you're kind of not told but you're kind
of told that you're dim down a little
bit like your desires are dimmed um
or you're told that you know it's
completely gone but
it's a myth
we left the little village we lived in
and then
we went to
ethiopia
and then we waited for a visa from my
father who lived here
and once we got that we
came to
the uk london to be specific
when did you first start realizing
that you were different to some other
girls
um i didn't realize until i was in year
six
i think i might have been 11.
i remember we had a sex education
lesson at school
and i even
i even took my mom's signature just to
do it because she didn't want us to
learn it
but
everyone else was doing it so i felt you
know why because i didn't i didn't even
know what it was
um i didn't know english that well
and
i
forged my mum's signature
and i gave it to the teacher and i said
yes my mom was okay with it
and
we were given the lesson
the first
thing that they showed us was the
difference between male genitals and
female genitals but when i saw the
female genitals
i was like that
that's that doesn't look like mine
that's
what i was like what
um that was a massive massive massive
shock
to me
it wasn't one that i could openly speak
about either i felt
trapped
in a way
it also felt like it was almost
the western women were
bad
and my my practice was
like good if that made sense like
because i think our prey our brain we
are so we were programmed
in our brain
in my brain i was programmed to believe
you know
everything western is bad you know don't
so when i saw that i thought okay maybe
you know the vaginas look different
because
you know they're not clean or they're
not this but then i didn't know i wasn't
aware that it was
my practice the practice that was done
to me
it's what was bad
that idea of seeing western women as
you know the ones being wrong that
changed very quickly because i realized
actually
that's how
not it's not that's how my vagina is
supposed to look but
that's normal
like mind being closed is not normal it
doesn't feel normal it never felt normal
and from that moment on
it was just insecurity after insecurity
i was
suffering from
mental health problems i had the worst
mood swings
and to make it worse i got my period
when i was nine years old
and i didn't even know what a period was
no one had explained that to me so when
i got it it came as a massive surprise
and
i almost like
free i actually freaked out because i
thought i was gonna die
you know why why am i bleeding
and my mom explained everything and told
me to use a pad but one thing she said
that really
stuck with me is don't tell anyone
don't tell anyone that you've
you you know your you now have your
period don't tell anyone i think that
was also seen as shameful
and also within my culture if a woman
has her period she's now a woman
and but in my mind i'm like wasn't i not
a woman when you guys did the the fgm
procedure like how am i just becoming a
woman now
so i was questioning a lot and
i really struggled with my period
every single month i ended up in a e
because they had nowhere
nowhere to come out
and
i went multiple times
doctors never did anything
there wasn't
any
type of solution given to me in terms of
you know
helping me
get my period a lot smoother or you know
there's these procedures not nothing was
ever told to me
um
it was i lived in constant pain
like my periods were
they they wouldn't come out so it would
get stuck
and i would have to either um get a hot
water bottle or drink hot water
or just scream in agony until
it passes
and when i was 14 years old i started
tearing as a result of my period not
having anywhere to come out from
and
it was another type of pay i don't even
know how to describe that pain either
because
it's
it's all i can say is staring and you
know when people ask me what do you mean
tearing
that that's what i mean i'm
tearing there's no other way for me to
explain like i'm sold so i'm tearing
when i was in high school i found out
that
um
this procedure that i knew as guditan or
female circumcision is actually known as
female genital mutilation in this
country in the uk
and i think when
i think when i heard the word um
you know female genital mutilation i'm
like how could i ever
go to anyone and say that i'm mutilated
like
explaining my experience is bad enough
by having to sit there and admit
that you're damaged in some way or that
because mutilation to me is damaged
something that can can't be fixed
something
that's not that's not reversible almost
it's gruesome it's and yes the practice
is
but i am not you know
um and that added to my insecurities and
i think because of that i just thought i
just i i felt so uncomfortable till now
i feel really uncomfortable saying that
i've had
um fgm
they say now you know you should look
for signs of whether
a child has been subjected to fgm or not
it's almost impossible it is almost
impossible especially from the community
that i'm from
children don't show the same signs and
symptoms um especially of trauma because
we are taught and we're taught so well
to keep it in
you know just hide it so deep down that
just never bothers you
it's
i think more conversations need to be
had with children rather than
waiting for signs that are just never
going to appear because
in high school i was a troublemaker i
had the worst mood swings
um i was never reserved
i was loud i was happy i was
you know active
my sister on the other hand was you know
very reserved calm collected
but you would never think that me and
her have ever had this procedure
have any medical professionals in the uk
tell you anything like
did they try to talk to your mom try to
talk to you try to comfort you
help in any way
no
every single time i was examined
first of all it is the most
horrible thing that i
have ever put myself through um
because you want i don't know i don't
even know what i was looking for um but
i needed
something like i knew that this wasn't
okay so i didn't understand why
i wasn't being given any advice or any
i didn't even know about reconstructive
surgery until what's a year ago
and as ridiculous as it sounds is the
truth i did not know
and i am what 29 now
i was seven when i came here and not one
doctor one nurse one gynecologist ever
said to me
you know
here are some options this is um if you
want to you know open this is called um
defibrillation we can do that for you or
if you want a reconstruction surgery
there is this option
nothing
nothing ever
why
i can
only guess
i have two guesses one is
they were not trained
on female genital cutting or female
genital mutilation
um
or
they don't want to come across as um
or they don't want to be targeted for
racism or discrimination
but you're a doctor
your job as a doctor
is to give medical advice so what could
i have seen that
i don't know that i could like i don't
know i there's no way that i would have
ever said you know
you're a racist or you are
discriminating against me because
you've noticed that i have fgm
the medical professions who
could be doing so much
for these survivors in terms of helping
with their trauma with
their
physical image
they don't really
care to be honest that's what i took
from it anyway from my personal
experience
i don't think they ever cared
to advise me even
so
every chance i get to speak to someone i
would tell them everything
everything whether they wanted to listen
or not
they were going to hear it
and it made me feel so good to
let everything out because i was so used
to it being my secret
like it made me realize that they were
so
sympathetic
towards me and they weren't shaming me
and they weren't
looking at me like i had done something
wrong
so when i got married i had just turned
18.
and
i remember
him coming in
and the whole time i was in that room i
was thinking how are you going to escape
i said to myself
some so you have two choices today
one you can either get raped
now
or you can just go with it
um so that
it doesn't happen in a violent way
the woman who's the cutter came with a
razor and
had done something down there but i
wasn't aware what
wasn't really particularly aware of what
she did i remember the pain so
distinctly we weren't sedated
the pain the pain was excruciating it
was excruciating as you remember crying
i do remember screaming